[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام هل باتت الصين
تهدد النظام الدوليه الذي تقوده امريكا
بعد وساطتها الناجحه بين ايران والعرب
اليس من السخف التبشير بان بكين صارت تهدد
المجال الحيوي الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط
اليس حريا بالصين ان تحل مشكله تايوان
خاصرتها الرخوه قبل ان تتنطع لحل قضايا
دوليه
اليس ما يسمى ببحر الصين بحرا امريكيا
بالفعل وصينيا بالاسم فقط فاذا كانت
امريكا تحاصر الصين من كل حدب وصوب فكيف
نتوقع من بكين ان تهدد العرش الامريكيه في
العالم العربي او غيره
لكن في المقابل اليست دخول الصيني على خط
الازمات في الشرق الاوسط مؤشرا قويا على
ان العالم بدا يتغير فعلا اليس دليلا على
بدايه عالم متعدد الاقطاب اليس مجرد لجوء
حلفاء امريكا الى الوساطه الصينيه مؤشرا
على اضمحلال النفوذ الامريكي في منطقتنا
من كان يتصور قبل سنوات ان يكون التقارب
السعودي الايراني مثلا على ايد او على
ايدي القياده الصينيه حتى ولو بعلم امريكا
اسئله اطرحها عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من
عمان على المختص بالقضايا الدوليه حازم
عياد ومن امريكا على الدكتور عبد الله
الشمري الخبيري في الشان الامريكي وعضو
الحزب الديمقراطي الامريكي
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس لو بدات
معك من امريكا دكتور عبد الله
على ضوء
الوساطه الصينيه الناجحه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايران بدات ترتفع اصوات
كثيره تبشر العالم بظهور نظام عالمي جديد
باي باي امريكا كيف ترد
اولا مساء الخير دكتور وضيفك وكل من
يتابعنا
بدايتنا عن نفسي يؤمن ان الاحاديه لله
سوف يكون متوازن لابد من ان يكونوا متعدد
للاسف الواقع يقول اننا لازمنا نعيش زمن
القطبيه الاحاديه وسوف تستمر ونستمر على
هذه الحاله على الاقل بالمنظور لمده خمسين
او اكثر عام قادم
عزائي الوحيد انه هذا القطب الواحد الذي
يقود العالم هو
نعم قطب احادي
ولكن يعني بالثقافه بالسياسه
بالاقتصاد اما الذي يدعون انه منافسه
النظام الصيني هو نظام استبداد
الديكتاتوري هو ليس نظام الحزب الواحد
وانما نظام الفرد الواحد
لكي تستطيع ان تنافس الصين امريكا لازم
يكون عندها مقومات للمنافسه امريكا لما
وصلت لما وصلت اليه ما وصلته لانه في كان
مستشار بالباذنجان حلم انه تكون امريكا
منافس لا اشتغلت امريكا
بالقرن السابع عشر كانت
ما في دوله مستعمره ما استعمرتها
لكن حطت مشروع وحطت اجنده واشتغلت عليها
فعززت امنها الداخلي عزوز امنها الاقليمي
ثم اصبحت الدوله الاكثر امانا ثم اصبحت
الدوله مش هذا موضوعي دكتور ادخل لي
بالموضوع
ادخل بالموضوع
تتكلم عن امريكا يعتقدون انه الصين لما
تريد تكون منافس هكذا بدون اي شيء لكن
الصيني
الصين لا تنافس من دون اي شيء الصين تملا
الدنيا الان كيف يعني لا تنافس الصين تفضل
خلنا نشوف خلنا نشوف هذه الدنيا التي
تملاها بالاقتصاد امريكا رقم واحد
بالمؤشرات الاقتصاديه كلها سواء شبكات
البنوك شبكات المال شبكات البورصه كل
مقومات الاقتصاد ايضا بالارقام 21 تريليون
حجم الدخل الامريكي بينما الصين لا زالت
17 وهذه الارقام بالمناسبه لما الصين تعلن
انها 17 هي ارقام مشكوك فيها باعتراف
الرئيس الصيني بخطاب 21 انه لانه عندهم
مشكله ما في شفافيه على عكس من الاقتصاد
الامريكي اللي عنده شفافيه محاسبه هناك لا
في شرعيه الارقام مثل ما تبيعها النظام
الصيني يحطونها مثل موضوع التصويت
بتجديد للرئيس الصيني تصدق مئه بالمئه
تجاوزه
المقاييس العربيه 99.99 وصلوا مئه بالمئه
هذه الارقام مسكوك فيها ولكن خلنا
نعتمد
عسكري ايش عدد القواعد السلاح ميزانيه
الدفاع الامريكيه تقريبا تريليون
بالاساطير حامله الطائرات عدد الجنود
الترسان النوويه اعطيني دوله ممكن تنافس
امريكا بالمؤشر العسكري بالدبلوماسيه 181
سفاره حول العالم 254 بعثه حول العالم
200,000 موظف وزاره الخارجيه
بالسياسه مسيطره على القرار السياسي
العالمي بالمناسبه مشان ما يفوتني حيث
توجد سفاره امريكيه يوجد
قرار القرار الامريكي واذا ما كان القرار
في هناك بالسفاره الامريكيه مكتب للسياقه
لاداره ما يجب ان ان تقوم به الفكره وما
فيها انه لما نتكلم عن الصين انها منافس
اعطيني مؤشر واحد نعم الصين منافس ولكنها
منافس صنع في امريكا
الصين عندما تريد ان تكون منافس عليها ان
تقوم باشياء كثيره ليس بمجال الاقتصاد
ممكن بالاقتصاد ممكن ربما ولكن ايضا
بالاقتصاد الصين بعام 1990 قبل ما تنفتح
عليها امريكا طبعا الانفتاح بدا من ال71
لكن بالافت الانفتاح الحقيقي او سياسه
الاحتواء بدات بالتسعين كانت الصدر شحاطات
بلاستيك الان وصلت الى ما وصلت اليه بسبب
سياسه الاحتواء لممارسه امريكا مع الصين
واللي فرضتها على حلفائها واعطتها تفضيلات
تجاريه خلت الصين تصل الى ما وصل بالاضافه
انها صدرت لها
واصبح الصيني بهذا المستوى انا بالنسبه لي
الصين نعم منافس ولكن منافس صنع في امريكا
مثلها مثل هواوي هواوي قبل ثلاث سنوات
كانت من اكبر خمس شركات بالعالم اليوم
هواوي رئيس شركه هواوي قبل اسبوعين ثلاثه
يقول حنا الان نصارع من اجل البقاء
الصين
لما نتكلم عن الصين هل الصين هي هي اللي
تصرح انها راح تكون منافس لامريكا الصين
كانت نعم كانت التنين ولكن لكي يصل الى ما
وصلوا اليه تحوله الى باندا عندما تريد ان
تتحول الى تنين ترجع الى عام 1990 او ممكن
نرجع الى قبل ما 1990 الى عام 1971 بزياره
لانه الصين قبل ما تكون الصين الشعبيه
المعترف فيها
عام
1971 كانت غير معترف فيها كان المعترف
فيها تايوان الصين اذا تريد بالفعل ان
يكون لها شان تفعل مثل ما سويت امريكا
تحرر محيط الاقليمي تفرض سيطرتها على
تايوان تفرض سيطره على هونج كونج تحرر
الجزر من اليابان او المناطق الثانيه او
جزر في الفلبين
تبسط نفوذه وسيطرته على
بحر الصين اللي الان بحر الصين عباره عن
ملعب للاساطير الامريكيه
باختصار باختصار بجمله واحده ماذا تريد ان
تقول كي اذهب الى السيد حسن نعم الصين اذا
لابد ان يكون منافس الصين منافس صنع في
امريكا الصين منافس لامريكا ولكنه صنع في
امريكا سيد حاسم كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
يعني انا عجبني مدخله الى الموضوع ولكنه
نسي ان يذكر ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لديها ايضا سجون سريه في 54
دوله في العالم منها 24 دوله اسلاميه و12
دوله عربيه وعشر دول افريقيه تنتشر فيها
سجون السريه الامريكيه في انحاء العالم
هذا واحد من منتجات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ايضا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لديها نصف مليون
مواطن امريكي يحملون الجنسيه الامريكيه
وهؤلاء ايضا يحملون الجنسيه الاسرائيليه
يعيشون فسادا في الضفه الغربيه ويشاركون
بالهجمات على الفلسطينيين في حواره وفي
قتل الفلسطينيين وفي تدريب الميليشيات
الاسرائيليه على قتل الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه ولا يحاكم ولا مواطن امريكي يحمل
الجنسيه الامريكيه عندما يدخلون الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم حرب
في الضفه الغربيه وفي المناطق والمستوطنات
التي كانوا يعيشون فيها او كانوا يقضون
الصيف هم فيها انا لا اريد ان اتناول هذا
الموضوع والتحديث عن فضاء الامريكان لكن
موضوعي هل الصين فعلا تمثل منافس حقيقي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا هو موضوعي
تفضل الصين نعم النظام النظام الدولي يتجه
نحو التعدديه القطبيه الاقتصاديه وهذا ما
تعبر عنه الارقام التي يكشفها بنك الدولي
وليست الصين البنك الدولي يقول ان حجم
الاقتصاد الصيني هو 18 مليار دولار 18
تريليون دولار الاقتصاد الامريكي هو بين
23 تريليون دولار الاقتصاد الاتحاد
الاوروبي هو يعني يقارب الاقتصاد الصيني
بمقدار 18 تريليون دولار اي ان الصين
والاتحاد الاوروبي بمجموعه كدول تتقاربان
في حجم الناتج القومي الناتج الاجمالي
طبعا الهند تبتعد كثيرا عن هذه الارقام
ولكن الكتله اسيان والدول للجنوب شرق اسيا
تجمع هذا القدر من الناتج العالمي اذا
النظام الدولي يتجه نحو تعدديه اقتصاديه
وهذه التعدديه الاقتصاديه اصبح يعبر عنها
من خلال مؤسسات دوليه
وبعد الحرب الاوكرانيه اصبح هناك حاجه
للتعبير عن هذا التنوع والتعدديه
الاقتصاديه لتجنب العقوبات الامريكيه
ولتجنب السياسه الامريكيه العدائيه تجاه
هذه التعدديه هي تحاول ان تحطم النموذج
الاوروبي الاقتصادي من خلال يعني توريط
اوروبا في الحرب الاوكرانيه ومن خلال
البريكسيت الذي شجعت عليه
شركتها
للخروج من لاضعاف الاتحاد الاوروبي واضعاف
سعودي كقوه اقتصاديه منافسه ويعني موازيه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن خلال
اشعال الحرب في في اوكرانيا في محاوله
ايضا خلق صراعات في تايوان وتبريد الصين
واضعاف اقتصاديا والحد عبر العقوبات التي
سبقها يعني هي سياسه امريكيه استراتيجيه
قام بها ترامب وليست سياسه فقط بايدن حاول
ان يفرض عقوبات على الصين للحد من نموه
الاقتصادي امريكا تبذل جهودا جباره
لتحطيم هذه التعدديه الاقتصاديه والعالم
يتجه لها الان هذه نتيجه الحرب الاوكرانيه
اصبح هناك تعبير سياسي عنها تحاول الصين
الدفاع عن هذه الانجازات التي حققتها
تحاول من خلال
توسيع يعني نشاطاتها الاقتصاديه وحتى
تحالفاتها السياسيه وتحاول ان تلعب دور في
المناطق التي في لديها فيها مصالح قويه
تدعم هذه التعدديه خلينا ننتقل العربيه
سيد حسن خلينا ناخذ المنطقه العربيه يا
اخي بس دقيقه بس دقيقه
السؤال المطروح هل فعلا هل فعلا يعني يمكن
ان نصدق بان الصين بدات يعني تقتحم
المجالات الحيويه للولايات المتحده وخاصه
في الشرق الاوسط يعني حتى الان لا يمكن
باي حال من الاحوال ان نصدق مثل مثل هذا
الكلام انت تعلم الشرق الاوسط ليس هناك بس
دقيقه سيد حازم ليس هناك نظام واحد في
الشرق الاوسط ولا حاكم واحد جاء الى
السلطه من دون ضوء اخضر امريكي ومباركه
امريكيه من الذي يستطيع ان يخرج عن الطوق
الامريكي يا استاذ حازم في الشرق الاوسط
كي نطبل للصين انت بتعلم ترامب ماذا يقول
للعرب وغيرهم انتم ما فيكم تطلعوا
بطائراتكم اصلا من دون حمايه امريكيه
الامريكان يعني متغلغلين في كل في كل يعني
الاسلاك اذا صح التعبير اسلاك الحكم في في
العالم العربي يعني مجرد انه الصين مجرد
انه الصين مجرد انه الصين اتواصلت بين
السعوديه وايران خلص الصين اكلت امريكا
كلام مضحك يعني بصراحه
الاول ليتعلق بالصين السؤال الاول من شقين
الاول يتعلق بالصين ولا اخر يتعلق
بالمنطقه العربيه الصين هي تعرضت لهجمه
امريكيه تراد من خلالها في مناطق نفوذ
الصين يراد من خلالها توريط الصين بصراعات
والمحاصرتها وحاولت امريكا ان تنشر مجموعه
من التحالفات الاقتصاديه والامنيه لمحاصره
الصين والحد من نمو الاقتصادي اي ان
السياسه العدائيه اتخذت بمبادره من امريكا
وبدات بسلسله من العقوبات ابرز ما فيها
النص ان مشكله امريكا مع الصين ان الصين
هناك عجز تجاري اقتصادي بين الصين
والولايات الامريكيه ويجب المعالجه من
خلال العقوبات ومن خلال فرض سياسات حمائيه
ومن خلال خلق ازمات للصين هذا دفاع الصيني
سياسه دفاعيه سياسه دفاعيه تتطلب انك انت
تدافع عن مصالحك سواء في جنوب شرق اسيا او
في المنطقه العربيه اعلم ان ان نسبه النمو
في التجاره المتبادليه بين المنطقه
العربيه والصين نمت بمقدار اربع مرات في
15 عام الماضيه من 100 مليار دولار الى
نصف تريليون دولار هي حجم التجاره بين
الصين والمنطقه العربيه
بما فيها ايران وباكستان وتركيا هذه
الحجم التبادل التجاري يوازي نفس حجم
التبادل التجاري بين امريكا الان ونفس حجم
التبادل التجاري بين اوروبا والصين
في حين ان المنطقه الوحيده التي تتوفوق
المنطقه العربيه بحجم التجاره هي منطقه
اسيان 600 مليار 600 مليار دولار حجم
التجاره بيني وبين الصين الصين لديها
مصلحه قويه في تنميه علاقاتها لانها سريعه
النمو حجم النمو العام الماضي كان 35
بالمئه
في التجاره التبادليه بينها وبين العالم
العربي اذا هذه المصالح المشتركه التي
بدات تظهر بين الصين وبين المنطقه العربيه
تدفع الصينيين الى الاهتمام باستقرار وامن
هذه المنطقه لانها مصلحه صينيه تخدم
مصالحها اذا ما قررت امريكا ان تفرض مزيد
من العقوبات جميل جدا جميل جدا سيد حسن
ستمثل جميل منطقه امان للصين اندفاع
طبيعيه ومنطقيه وتعبر عن سلوك دفاعي صيني
جميل جدا الدكتور عبد الله كيف ترد تفضل
مركز على العامل الاقتصادي انا بس اريد
اساله سؤال
من اي بنك البنك المركزي الصيني لما يرفع
الفائده ولا الفيدرالي لما يرفع الفائده
يهتز العالم
يرفع البنك الفيدرالي
درجه جميع بنوك العالم لازم
انا اقول لضيفك انه اكبر اربع بنوك
بالعالم هي بنوك صينيه ممكن يقول لي اسم
واحد منها بينما لو سالت اي واحد الكل
يعرف امريكا
عامل الاقتصاد لما نتكلم بعمل الاقتصاد في
مؤشرات ما هو بس معدل الدخل في عنا التضخم
البطاله نسبه البطاله عشان نصل الى ارقام
حقيقيه لازم نقارن بين عام 1990 واليوم
نسبه البطاله في الصين كانت اثنين ونص
بالصين اثنين ونص بالميه اليوم وصلت الى
سته فاصله اربعه بينما نسبه البطاله
بامريكا في 90 كانت خمسه فاصله اربعه وصلت
اليوم الى 4.6
التضخم التضخم بالصين الان واصل بالمؤشرات
الى حوالي 7% بعد ان كان اثنين اليوم
التضخم بامريكا وصل الى 5% هي هذه
المقاييس ما هو لانه بسنه واحده ومعدل
الهجوم الصيني على المنطقه الهجوم الصيني
على الشرق الاوسط تفضل
دعوه الصين انا شبهه ايش
نعم الصين عندهم قوه بشريه هائله هي نفس
قوه العرب لما امتلك هو الطاقه الهائله
اللي هي عصبه الاقتصاد وعصب السياسه شو
عملوا فيها ما سووا بينما الصين بعام 1949
انفصل التايوان عنها تايوان اللي يتكلم
عنها السياسيون يقولون هي حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه التي لم تغرق سبحان الله نفس
المؤشر 70 سنه وتايوان منفصله تحت اداره
امريكيه واسرائيل من سبعين سنه ايضا
انفصلت عن العالم العربي شو سووا كلها
تصريحات ولاءات
وبالنهايه تصريحات فاضيه تشوفها انا اعطيك
الصين عدد القواعد ضيفك انا سمعت المقابل
يقول عدد القواعد لانه ناقله من جوجل 750
قاعده او 730 قاعده جويه انا اضيف
المعلومات وعدد القواعد الامريكيه
العسكريه حول العالم اكثر من 1200 قاعده
الصين ما عندها الا قاعده وحده بجيبوتي
وعندها قاعده سمعنا عنها بالاعلام انها
بالامارات ثم جاء العتيبه ورئيس الاركان
الاماراتي قالوا هذه قاعده لوجستيه لخدمه
القواعد الامريكيه القاعده الامريكيه
والفرنسيه هي عباره عن
مانيكير باديكير وحلاقه ومساج هذا هو دور
الصين الصين هي قاعده لوجستيه لخدمه
المصالح الامريكيه بالاراده الامريكيه
لانه الامبراطوريات يا دكتور لا يمكن ان
تستمر بدون منافس من الافضل ان يكون عندك
منافس مثل الصين
صناعه امريكيه اقتصاد خلي مهما تكلموا
بالارقام الامريكان يعرفون وش الارقام
بالمستوى اللي قالوا ضيفك اللي هو قال انه
العالم يتغير نعم صحيح العالم يتغير ونعم
الصين راح يكون له دور منافس بالاقتصاد
وراح نسمع لانه هذا اللي تريده امريكا خطه
امريكا لازم نفهم احنا مشكلتنا نروح بالع
جه خطه امريكا انه نحن لازم هذه
كرروها واكدوها بكره نحن لازم ننسحب من
المنطقه الانسحاب من المنطقه يولد فراغ
هذا الفراغ يجب ان
يعبيه جهه نحن نقدر نديرها ما نترك الامور
لحظه لحظه لحظه لحظه لحظه لحظه لو سمحت
الصيني الى الشرق الاوسط هي دخلت انسحاب
يعني طيب طيب
امريكا امريكا عندها توازنات عندها
مراجعات يقول لك نحن اذا ضلينا على
هالمستوى هذا راح نغرق راح يصير فينا مثل
ما صار الامبراطوريات الثانيه نحن بحاجه
انه ننطق
ونرجع مثل ما
سمعنا من بايدن وغيره نعيد بنيتنا التحتيه
نعيد بناء الراجحي حساباتنا هذه المرحله
شوف الشرق الاوسط بالنسبه لامريكا مستنقع
انا اعطيك مؤشر مهم هذا حجم الاقتصاد
امريكا بالالفين 2005 كان عندها سقف الدين
العام عشره تريليون بالالفين وخمسه من
الالفين وخمسه للثلاثه وعشرين وصل الى 31
الت ريليون تعرف شنو السبب
تغ
رقنا القاع مستنقع الشرق الاوسط هذه بعد
على فكره بالعام 1980 كان سقف الدين لا
يتجاوز 30% من الدخل نحن اليوم وصلنا الى
125% السبب ليش السبب لانه مثل ما تفضلت
لانه لو بقت امريكا انها تفقد سيطرتها او
تفقد جزء من كان تخلت عن بعض الانفاق
الزائد اللي يقدر بحدود اربعه
يعني باختصار ماذا تريد ان تقول تريد ان
تقول ان امريكا تريد ان تورط الصين
منافس لامريكا صنع في امريكا جميل الصين
لولا ضوء اخضر امريكي
رئيس
الصين رئيس الصين يقول نحن نعيش زمن
الارهاب الالكتروني رئيس الصين يقول نحن
محاصرين هذه الدوله التي تريد تنافس
امريكا تتكلم بهالمنطق شوف لعلمك
هذه الزياره اليوم اللي هي على اساس
يشيدون فيها زياده الرئيس الصيني لا لا
روسيا ولا شايف ان الاعلام هذا اللي يريده
هذا اللي تريده امريكا تريد تخلق
دكتور بل منهاج الامريكي
قالت لا زالت
تركز امه الامريكيه هو الحزب الشيوعي طيب
الاتحاد السوفيتي انتهى من عام 1990
والصين لولا الدعم الامريكي ما صارت الصين
اذا عن اي حزب شيوعيتك هذه السياسه
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه يهيؤون المنافس
وبعدين يطلعونه على الساحه ويبداون
يشتغلون عشان تكون امبراطوريه ويستمرون
هذا
لو ما هذا يا دكتور امريكا ازاحت المانيا
المانيا الامبراطوريه بالحرب العالميه
الاولى ازاحت المانيا النازيه واليابان
بالحرب العالميه الثانيه ازاحه الاتحاد
السوفيتي وفكفكتو اللي كان مضيفك يطبل له
الاتحاد فجاه صحينا
منو اقوى معايس القوه العسكريه
والاقتصاديه والنفوذ والتحالفات الاتحاد
السوفيتي ولا الصيني الاتحاد السويدي اللي
كان مسيطر على اوروبا الشرقيه اللي كان
عنده اكبر ترسان نوويه ماذا حل فيه لا
تراهنون على قربه لا تنفخون بقربه مقطوعه
الصين حالها نعم دوله اقليميه لها نفود كل
ما تقوم به الصين صدقوني بضوء اخضر انا
العب جميل جدا
وصلت الفكره دكتور وصلت الفكره سيد حسن
كيف ترد على هذا الكلام يعني يعني
نحن سمعناها انه كل هذه الوساطه الصينيه
بين ايران والسعوديه كانت
بضوء اخضر امريكي وكان يعني الوفد صحيفه
سعوديه تقول نحن او الوفد السعودي كان
يخبر امريكا بكل تفاصيل المفاوضات التي
ترعاها الصين وامريكا كانت تطلع على كل
شيء يعني وانت تعلم سيد حازم يعني سؤال
بسيط هل يمكن لاي اتفاق بين دول المنطقه
ان ينجح اذا تعارض مع المصالح الامريكيه
لا يمكن لا يمكن تستطيع امريكا ان تدمر اي
اتفاقيات تدمر اي اتفاقيات واحد زائد واحد
يساوي اثنين اذا نجاح فيما لو نجح هذا
الاتفاق فهذا يعني فهذا يعني فيما لو نجح
هذا الاتفاق فهذا يعني انه يعني تحت
المباركه الامريكيه باختصار شديد ميدن
امريكا كيف ترد
اعتقد انه هذا الكلام مردود عليه لانه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حاولت ان يعني
تفشل اتفاق بلس وجاء الرئيس الامريكي
بنفسه
فض هذا الاتفاق بين روسيا وبين دول اوبك
بلس وتتزعم وكانت السعوديه ورفضت السعوديه
الانصياع للاراده الامريكيه في هذا الملف
ايضا هذه القضيه الرعايه اتفاق بين الصين
بين السعوديه وايران ويعبر بالبدايه هذا
الاتفاق عن رغبه البلدين ايران والسعوديه
بالتوافق فيما بينهما وانهاء ملف صدام
الشيعي السني وانهاء ملف الصدام الاقليمي
الذي كانت توظفها امريكا
يعني تبرير وجودها العسكري في المنطقه
العربيه ولتبرير سياساتها ومحاولاتها
لادماج اسرائيل بحجه ان ايران تمثل خطرا
على دول الخليج انتهى هذا الخطر بت
الاتفاق فكل استراتيجيه الامريكيه الان
اصبحت مختله يعني خطابها سياسي اصبح يعني
مردودا عليها ولم يعد لديها مبرر لتفسر
علاقه اسرائيل بالمنطقه العربيه وبدول
العربيه كل هذه الاستراتيجيه الان عرضه
لتفكك والانتهاء كيف تكون امريكا راضيه عن
هذا الاتفاق وهي العداء لايران وفي عصب
استراتيجيتها الصراع السني الشيعي هو احد
مبررات القويه لوجودها هذا استراتيجيه
الامريكيه كلها مهدده من الذي التقط هذه
اللحظه الصينيين عرضوا على السعوديه يعني
هم يقدموا الرعايه لهذا الاتفاق باعتارهم
قوه اقتصاديه وقوه لها مصالح
اقتصاديه كبيره في المنطقه ومعنيه
باستقرار هذه المنطقه لضمان هذه نمو هذه
العلاقات الاقتصاديه امريكا لم يكن في
منطقه ان تكون الراعيه لهذا الاتفاق مجرد
ما ان قدمت الصين نفسها كراعي لهذا
الاتفاق وافقت السعوديه وايران وهذا منطقي
جدا انه ايران الصين ملات فراغ لا تستطيع
امريكا ان تملاه لانه استراتيجيه الصينيه
الامريكيه تتناقض تماما مع هذا التوجه
فبالتالي نحن نستطيع ان نقول ان هذا
الاتفاق لا ينسجم بالمطلق مع السياسه
والاستراتيجيه الامريكيه نتيجه حضور الصين
نتيجه انه سينهي وسيؤدي الى تبريد الصراع
في المنطقه وخصوصا قضيه التسعير الصراع
السن الشيعي الذي كانت تنظر له مؤسسه
ستراند الامريكيه التي
التي الجميع يعلم ما هي طبيعه
الاستراتيجيه التي طرحت قبل 20 عاما لخلق
صراع سن شيعي ونجحت فيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لحد كبير نعم امريكا استنزفت في
المنطقه نتيجه حروبها في افغانستان ونتيجه
حروبها في العراق ولكنها في المقابل ايضا
لا زالت تستنزف العراق لازال العراقيين كل
ما بدهم يبيعوا برميل نفط واحد يجب ان
يرسل هذا ثمن هذا النفط الى نيويورك الى
حساب في نيويورك لا زالت امريكا تتحكم
بشؤون العراق ولا يمكن للعراقيين ان
يتحرروا ان يخرجوا من حاله العجز التنموي
والعجز السياسي بدون ان يتحرروا من هذا
النفود الصين تطرح نفسها كبديل
وتطرح اليوان كبديل هذا الامر وهنا هذا
يمثل تهديد كبير لسياسه الامريكيه
سيد حسن سيد حسن سيد حسن سيد حسن يعني سيد
حسن لذلك يتوقع ان يكون هناك رده فعل
امريكيه متصاعده
لا لا لا لا ماشي ماشي بس 30% لليورو
واربعين بالمئه في تراجع انا قلت لك ان
هناك تعدديه اصلا ازمه امريكا الاقتصاديه
جزء منها هو تاكل مكانه الدولار يعني ازمه
البنوك ليست فقط نتيجه السندات بل ايضا
لانه هناك عوامل مساعده اخرى من بينها
صعود اليوان صحيح صعود بطيء لكنه يتضاعف
على شكل متواليه هندسيه يقلق حساسه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه جميل اذا دخلت
الصين الى العراق وهناك مقاومه شرسه
امريكيه للنفوذ الصيني في العراق
ومحاوله للسيطره على الدينار العراقي
وادخال العراق في ازمه اقتصاديه وفرض
عليها الابتعاد عن الصين بحجه انه والله
عشان انهم 11 مليار بيستوردوا 11 مليار من
ايران لكن في الحقيقه الهدف هو الصين لانه
اذا دخل اليوان الصيني الى العراق
فكل الدولارات بيع النفط اللي هو اربعه
ونصف برميل
الدولار الدولار يعاني من تضخم يعني من
مشكله انه الدولار اللي كان يجيب
يعني
سيجاره الان انت تحتاج الى خمس دولارات
لتشتري باكيت دخان او عشره دولارات جميل
جدا لانه الدولار قيمه التراجع
بازمه حقيقيه تتشكل وتكبر لا استطيع ان
اقول لك انه العالم سيتغير في الغد ولكن
اقول ان العالم بدا يتغير لان هناك دول
عربيه تتمرد حلو حلو حلو
اقليميه تتمرد على الاراده الامريكيه
هذا ما رايناه قبل ايام حلو جدا دكتور عبد
الله هذه النقطه
دكتور عبد الله خليني اسالك دكتور عبد
الله هذه النقطه تحديدا
الوساطه الصينيه هي نقطه فاصله معلم
تاريخي اذا صح التعبير في تاريخ العلاقات
الدوليه
والمؤشر على ذلك يعني المهم في هذا ليس
تدخل الصين في هذا المجال الحيوي الامريكي
فقط بل كما قال السيد حازم قبل قليل هناك
حاله تمرد هناك ركز لي على موضوع التمرد
هناك حاله تمرد حاله التمرد مثلا عندما
السعوديه الخليج الدول العربيه الجميع بدا
يتمرد في وجه الجبروت الامريكي روح لي
عليها مباشره
موضوع العراق ليش تروح للعراق روح اللبنان
العراق في قواعد في جيش في عسكر امريكي
لبنان حزب الله مسيطره على لبنان لبنان
يعاني من ازمات كهرباء
الصيني قاعد يجي يعرض عليه يقول له اسوي
لك كل شيء بالمجان يقول لك والله ننتظر
موافق امريكيه ما بدهم شي من امريكا ممنوع
هذا المثل اللبناني اللي حزب الله على
اساس هو اللي مسيطر وموجود وما في قواعد
امريكيه بلبنان وعنده الجاره السوريه اللي
هي زي ما انتم عارفين والايرانيين
الموجودين هل يستطيع الصيني ان ينفذ اي
مشروع في لبنان هذا البلد المتهاوي
المتهالك لانه ما في ضوء اخضر امريكي
ممنوع وقس على ذلك لا يمكنك
امريكا تقاوم النفوس الصيني قلقه من الصين
اذا امريكا تقاوم لا لا لا
في داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي اذا هناك
مقاومه هناك حاله من التجارب بدانا نشهدها
ومحاولات امريكيه
الصيني معلومات
عفوا
اكمل عبد الله بنفس
اكمل بنفس السياق بعد المثل اللبناني لا
يمكن للصين لا يمكن ان للصين ان تتصرف في
اي بقعه قبل ان تحرر تايوان الصين الان هي
مطوقه انا ما اريد اتكلم لك عن الاحلام لا
الاكتروس ولا الاقواد ولا
الاتفاقيه اللي وقعوها العام الماضي مع 14
جزيره
الصين عندها قاعده جيبوتي وعندها جزر
سليمان اللي رفضت الانضمام للاتفاقيه اللي
وقعت بين الامريكان
والجزر
لا يمكن ان
اقتصاد الصيني لو الامريكاني يسكرون
الحنفيه يتكلم لي عن قبل شوي عن موضوع
الاقتصاد في مؤشر اهم
حجم سوق السندات الصينيه الحكوميه
بالاقتصاد العالمي بسوق السندات العالميه
6% امريكا 60 ولكن لولا السندات الامريكيه
ما في نظام للسندات العالميه يعني النظام
شوف امريكه لذلك امريكا تعاني منها خطيره
جدا لا يوجد بديل لها حتى الان
موضوع التمرد على امريكا كمل لي على موضوع
التمرد حكيت عن لبنان بقيه الدول العربيه
الدول العربيه التي تتمرد على امريكا هل
هو تمرد لا يمكن لا يمكن للدول العربيه
ولا غيرها ان تتمرد الا
امريكيه هامش مناوره مسموح له اصلا
الوساطه اللي صارت لانه في اتفاقيه راح
يوقعون عليها الامريكان والايرانيين هي
الاتفاقيه النوويه امريكا قاعد تحاول
تتخلص من الاوراق اللي لازم تدفع لقائها
اثمان اعطت الملف للصين وراحت للسعوديه
تصالحت مع ايران بكره لما تقعد امريكا
وتبي تفاوض بكره يوقعون اتفاق النووي مو
في اوراق على الطاوله كان من ضمن الاوراق
هو الخلاف السعودي الايراني السعوديين
يقولون نحن لازم تكون الفاتوره مو حسابنا
الايرانيين يقول لازم تعطونا وصلوا لحل
تفاهم روحي الصين خذي هالورقه هذي وخلصونا
منها ولكن الهم الاساسي بالنسبه للامريكي
بالمجتمع الامريكي عند
الزبين هو موضوع اليمن وحرب اليمن لازم
تتوقف وهذا لازم يصير اهم شيء من الاتفاق
هو ايقاف حرب اليمن والمسؤولين الامريكان
من ترامب الى بايدن الى الخارجيه الى
ابو غمزه كلهم يقولون انه هذا الحرب لازم
تتوقف السعوديه عارفه انه اذا وقفت الحرب
وما حققت انسان عنده فاتوره تدفعها سواء
داخليا او خارجين على مستوى السياسه
العالميه لانه صورتها تهتز للاسف هذا هو
واقعنا انا اتمنى ان يكون الواقع مختلف
لكن واقع الحال اذا ما كان اذا ما كان
اتفاق عربي حقيقي صلب
مبني على اسس واضحه لا يمكن ان يكون للعرب
راي العرب شوف الان على مستوى على مستوى
اللي حصل اذا هذا الواقع ايضا اقدر انا
اعممه مع الصين لانه الصين عنده مؤشرات
عشان تكون دوله قويه لابد انها تمتلك زمام
القوى بالاقتصاد بالعسكره بالسياسه كل هذه
ولا تمتلك ولا شيء حتى الارقام انا مثل ما
قلت لك لانه ما في شفافيه الارقام منفوخه
والان الان الاقتصاد
الاقتصاد الصيني يعاني خلنا نتجاوز مرحله
اوكرانيا والحرب الاوكرانيه نعم العالم
هذا راح يتغير الامريكان راح ينسحبونه
للمنطقه انا اقول لك الصين وغيرها ممكن
يكون شريك باداره الفراغ لحساب امريكا
وليس ضد امريكا وسجلوها علي الصين اللي
تحولت من التنين الى بنده لا يمكن لها ان
ترجع الى التنين
الحكمه صينيه مهمه يقول في صراع الماء
والصخر
يتفتت الصخر وينتصر الماء هذا هو الصراع
بين الامريكان اذا كان في صراع انا اصلا
ما اشوف الصراع انا السياسه كانت
في فتره لها تحت مسمى
انخراط الحين صفت احتواء لغايه في نفس
صانع القرار الامريكي وانا قلت او اكررها
جميل جدا
هل ممكن انك تلعب دور انا اعطيك مثال
بس اعرف هذه الصين سالت نفسك انه هذا
الصين اللي عند الكتله البشريه الهائله
ليش عنده معدلات بطاله واجد لانه الصين
بحاجه الى عجله اقتصاد هذا الاقتصاد يحتاج
طاقه امريكا رافضه انه دول الخليج تعطي
الصين بالطاقه الا بما
يوافق او تتوافق معه المصالح الامريكيه
واحد
اذا امريكا ما وافقت انه يا الدوله
الفلانيه الخليجيه تعطينا الصين مليون
برميل سنويا او شهريا او يوميا ممنوع تعطي
مليون برميل
اعطيك مثال ثالث واضح وما يريد والرئيس
الصيني يعني مثل ما قال ببكي وبروح اللي
لما وقع على اتفاقيه المنام شنو يعني
اتفاقيه المناف تعرف شو يعني اتفاقيه
المناف يعني انه الصين ممنوع تستخدم الفحم
الحجري وهي كل اعتماد فهم الحجري لما
اجبرت ووقعت وارسل اتفاقيه العام الماضي
الرئيس الصيني شو قال قال نحن مجبرين وقع
غصب عنه هذه الامبراطوريه اللي انت تحلم
انه يكون نف
وذ ممكن انها تتخلى من اهم عامل من عوامل
قوه اقتصادها اذا كانت تطمح انها تكون
منافسه اقتصادي هو الفهم الحجري لانه ما
عندها طاقه الصين ما عندها مخازن لتخزين
النفط ما يعني ما عندها المقاومات هذه
عشان تكون الا بالرضا الامريكي والضوء
الاخضر الامريكي جميل جدا سيد حازم كيف
ترد
الرد بسيط يعني
هو ينفي عن الصين اي صفه بانها دوله تدافع
عن نفسها بكنها يعني دوله من دول الموز
تتبع للولايات المتحده الامريكيه الصين
استفادت من انشغال امريكا طوال العشرين
سنه الماضيه بين حربها على الارهاب
وبحروبها في العالم العربي والاسلامي
والمستنقع الذي اغرقتنا به واغرقت نفسها
وكانت تبني اقتصادا فجاه افاقت امريكا على
نفسها وجدت الصين على وشك ان تسبقها
اقتصاديا فبدات تخوض صراعات وتحاول ان
تحتوي الصين وتريد ان ان تسلم المنطقه
للكي يعني الاسرائيلي عبر اتفاقيات
ابراهيميه وغيرها من الاتفاقيات
لتقود اسرائيل هذه المنطقه
العربيه الدول العربيه
خلينا نكمل المتضرر
الاساسي من هذا الاتفاق واسرائيل
المظاهرات الامريكان في صراع داخل امريكا
وممتده الى الكيان الاسرائيلي حول مستوى
التدين والعلمانيه في بكلا البلدين هناك
صراع بين الرجاء المتدينين او الانجيليين
في امريكا وبين العلمانيين او اليساريين
المتقدمين حول مقدار العلمانيه ومقدار
الدين اناس يريدون ان يذهبوا بالتطرف الى
مستوى الشدود الجنسي
يعني الاباحيه الجنسيه وبين تيار لا يرفض
ذلك ويريد ان يجعل من الدين معيار
حتى للصراع في العالم ان هناك حرب مجدون
ان الى اخره هذا التيار الديني هذا الصراع
امتد يجد له بيئه قويه هو اصلا جوهره في
داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي نفس الشيء تياران
تيار ديني وتيار يعني علماني يعني قريب من
اليساري في امريكا يتصارعان جزء من
الامريكان الصهاينه ياتون ويتظاهرون في في
امريكا بالطائرات للتظاهر لانهم متضامنين
مع
بعيدا عن الامريكي يعني هذا هذا نعم بعيد
جدا هو طرحه هناك مشكله صراع كبير وانقسام
وشرخ داخل الولايات المتحده على المستوى
الاقتصادي في ازمه المستوى السياسي
والفكري والثقافي في ازمه الصين هنا
متفرغه يراد الان اشغال الصين بصراعات في
تايوان والصين ترفض ذلك الصين حاصرت قليلا
بس حاصرت تايوان توقفت مصادرات تايوان 90
70% من صادرات تايوان من الشرائح
الالكترونيه تذهب الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لم تستطع امريكا ان تتحمل ذلك
ما تستطيع
حاصرتها حاصرتها اثناء وجود السلم
[موسيقى]
ارسلت لهم يعني
بلالين تجسسيه مره ومرتين ولم تستطع
امريكا الا انت محرجه ان تسقط هذه
البلالين فوق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني في تحدي صيني الصين عينت وزير دفاع
عليه عقوبات من امريكا لا يعتبر هذا تحدي
الولايات من تحدي الامريكيه انت تعاقب
مسؤول صيني ويصبح الان وزيرا للدفاع في
الصين الا يمثل هذا التحدي للولايات
المتحده يمثل تحدي زياره الرئيس الصيني
لروسيا في في ذروه الحرب الاوكرانيه وفي
ذروه الربيع ايضا مؤشر على التحدي الصيني
للسياسه الامريكيه تقول للصين ضعيفه
عسكريه لكن لديها حليف نووي قوي هو روسيا
هناك مظله نوويه روسيه وهناك مظله
اقتصاديه صينيه تعملان تعملان
هذا التغير امريكا بتتكيف مع التغير انت
مش قادر
يا عم
حقك
سيد عبد الله
من المسلمين
خطا كبير ان نبقى متفرجين البقاء
بحق العرب الاسلاميه
انت هذا الموقع
نلعب دورنا راح نضلنا يعني خاضعين المشروع
الصهيوني الامريكي لا نريد ان نبقى
خليه يكمل خليه يكمل يا عبد الله
يريد ان يضرب علينا
توافق بين بعضكم سووا اتفاقات صحيحه صادقه
من بعضكم
بدنا نتوافق معه لان هذه الصراع بيننا
وبين لماذا يعني نمشي وفق الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه امريكا تريد صراع كل شيعي نريد
ان ننهي هذه المساله نريد ان ننتهي من
مساله صلاه الشيعي اذا اتفقت السعوديه
وايران لماذا لا نشجع عليه امريكا
استراتيجيه صلب استراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
في مجال انه يحدث فيه مساحه لنتحرك لنتنفس
بعيدا
انت قاعد تقول حرب وحرب
السودان تعرضت للسودان يا عزيزي تعرضت
لحصار اقتصادي 30 عام يحرمها من التنميه
الاقتصاديه انتهى فيه الامر الى انفصال
جنوب السودان 30 عام والسودان محاصر
مين اللي حاصره ومين اللي تسبب من
يعني
امريكا وسياساته الاجراميه امريكا
ماذا تسبب
بصراحه شيعي
مش شايف الديمقراطي ورجيني اياها وين
الديمقراطيه في العالم العربي لجذبت لنا
اياه امريكا
في جمعيه العالم الاسلامي
سيد حسن سيد حسن
عبد الله سيد حسن تفضل عبد الله بتاع
الوقت اختصار خلينا في امريكا والصين
راحت تحسيتي جاء الصين اليوم ترى نعصي
بكره يروح الصين تراهن على الهند السياسه
الاحتياط
مصالحة
شيعيه سنيه واذا كانت ايران
صيانه
سيد سيد حسن سيد حسن خليه كمل كمل بدون
مقاطعه يا عبد الله
حتى لما تريد امثله نصيحتي لك اضرب امثله
كويسه بدل ما تضرب بالسودان اقول الثلاثه
وشفنا وين راح السودان اضرب مثل بكوريا
كوريا اليوم محاصره مقاطعه ما ما عم
بتعاني ويقول انا موجود نعم انا ضده ولكن
المنطقه القوه هذه القوه وش عندك كوريا
انت بعام 1990 حجم اقتصادك يا عربي كان
عشر اقتصاد الصيني اليوم جاي تنظرني على
الاقتصاد الصيني بعد ما كنت نظر على
الاقتصاد الشريفي كفانا لعب بعقول الناس
لا تضحكون على الناس اذا نبي ويكون لنا
شان نرجع لنفسنا نبني قواتنا نستفيد من
مصادر طاقتنا ومصدر قوتنا عندنا قوه ليس
قوه بشريه الان انت الان جميل
الامريكيه
تغريده دكتور حازم او ما ادري انت دكتور
حازم امريكا امريكا عشان
تستخراب في العالم العربي طيب اشكرك لحظه
لحظه لحظه باختصار باختصار عبد الله انتهى
الوقت انتهى الوقت باختصار خلينا ناخذها
خلينا ننهي خلينا ننهي اذا الاختراق
الصيني للعالم العربي عبد الله بجمله
واحده الاختراق الصيني للعالم العربي
اختراق ام بضوء اخضر امريكي بجمله واحده
هو
هو احتراق وليس اختراق لانه الشرق الاوسط
مستنقع امريكا حتى اذا سمحت لاي دوله تريد
انها تحرقها لانه لانه امريكا انا اقول لك
ليش تغيرت
لانه امريكا دكتور لانه امريكا بدات
تستوعب انه الصين ما عاد تتحمل هذه هذه
القوه اللي عندها الان نحن رايحين الى
سياسه الانخراط مع الهند وسجلوها علي
الانخراط مع الهند واحتواء الصين بعد فتره
نفس اذا الله مد بعمرنا راح نكون انا وانت
ضيوفك على نفس الموضوع بس نتكلم عن الهند
وهل اخترقت العالم العربي
سيد سيد حسن سيد حسن سيد حسن بجمله واحده
اختراق ام احتراق بجمله واحده
صين انا اعتقد انه الصين تمكنت من هناك
تحقيق انجاز كبير في المنطقه العربيه
وتسعى لتحويل نفوذها الاقتصادي او مصالح
المشتركه مع المنطقه العربيه الى مصالح
سياسيه تخدم الطرفين العرب والصينيين
لكل الطرفين العرب والصينيين لان يخلقوا
هذه العلاقه المتطوره والمصالح المشتركه
شكرا جزيل الشكر مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى
لنا لا نشكر ضيفينا من عمان السيد حازم
عياد ومن امريكا عبد الله الشمبري
فحتى ذلك الحين وفيصل القاسم يحييكم من
الدوحه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]